So I want you to think about the last time
you failed miserably. I want you to think
about the last time you had the worst setback.
I want you to think about the last time something
didn't go your way. How did you respond to
that? What did you do right afterwards? We
learn a lot when that takes place. I once
heard a mentor of mine that told me, "You
learn a lot about a human being or yourself
when you have a major setback in your life."
Right? Because the reality part of it is,
when I'm about to tell you about small thinkers
is the basis of it, before I give you the
answer, the basis of it is small thinkers
have one enemy. It isn't their competition.
It isn't their parents. It isn't their girlfriend.
It isn't their spouse. It isn't their best
friend. It isn't their staff. It isn't their
customers. It isn't the market. They have
one enemy, and it's their mindset and the
way they think. That is the biggest problem
with small thinkers. So what is the one thing
small thinkers are experts at doing? Here's
what it is. They are experts EXPERTS, they're
incredibly, incredibly good at justifying
every single situation that happened to them.
Now don't get me wrong. I know this from experience.
I'm not telling you this as if I'm talking
at you. I did this for the majority part of
my life. Hey, Pat, the reason you're not going
to win is because you come from a divorced
family. You are this, you don't have a degree.
Constantly justifying. Well, because of this,
because of that. Not effective; it doesn't
work, right? So, I sat there and I said, I
was mentoring a couple of entrepreneurs and
I was sitting down with them. And I said,
"Can I ask you a question?" I was studying
one of the guy's trends who's got the potential
to make multi-seven figures, but I noticed
a certain trend. And I pulled him aside and
I said, "Can I ask you a question?" He said
yes. I said, "Can I ask why you justify every
single setback? Why do you do that? Why do
you sell to everybody? Because you can do
that every single time. Why is it that you
explain to everybody that what happened wasn't
your fault. And it's because of this and it's
because of that. Why do you do that?" And
I had this conversation because 16 years ago,
somebody had a very similar conversation like
this with me. And let me tell you that it
was the most annoying conversation I ever
had because we hate, listen, we hate to know
that something that happened was our fault.
We hate it. When a relationship breakup happens,
it's never our fault. It's always her fault.
When a relationship --it's never her fault;
it's his fault. When a business doesn't work,
it's the business' fault. It's the boss, it's
this, it's the team. It's always that. So
how do you find that if this is a trend that
you have or not. So let me give you three
different scenarios and I want you to answer
to yourself on how you respond to this.
So #1, first question, let's study this. How
do you respond to setbacks? What is your immediate
reaction to setbacks? So think about the last
two or three setbacks. What did you do? Truly
be honest with yourself. Did you blame anybody?
Did you blame the marketplace? Did you blame
a condition? Did you blame anything? Was there
anything? Or did you say, "Here's what happened.
I don't control this. I take responsibility
on this. I can work on this. This is what
I'm going to improve." Is that what you did?
Is that the behavior?
#2: Say you have a competitor that's doing
better than you. They're making more money
than you in a shorter period of time. Let's
just say this person is marketing better or
they're getting into new markets and you're
not. What is your reaction to that and how
do you explain that to your peers? Is it,
"Man, they are doing this better than us?"
Or is it, "Oh man, they got lucky. That guy
comes from family. Oh, they're probably doing
something shady. Oh, they're probably doing
something this. Oh they're. . ." You know,
we, because of. . . What do you do? How do
you react to it? Is the conversation, "Man,
we need to improve in these three areas. We
really need to. Guys, what do you think we
need to do to improve these two areas? These
guys are doing it this way. Man, we need to
be seeing what they're doing and we're not
doing. Are they working harder." I remember
one time, one time, I'll tell you this story.
I was going against this other agent.
And he had been there a shorter period of
time than I had. And he grew ten times faster
than me in a two year period. And he just
came and surpassed me during that period.
I'll never forget this. We're at a convention
and the executives made me at this time give
the trophy to the other guy. I'll never forget
this. I give the trophy to the other guy because
he won MVP and I didn't. And they wanted for
whatever reason, maybe I was going to be humiliated
or something like that, and I will remember
that 35-second scene in my life forever. Because
let me tell you what was crazy and what I
told myself when I got off the stage. Here's
what I told myself. The strangest thing. I
got off the stage and I say, "Wow, Pat, I'm
proud of you. You grew. You grew." Because
this was my response. I gave him the plaque
and I said, "I just want you to know this.
You have absolutely outworked me. But this
will be the last year. You won't even come
close. Because this will be the last time
you will ever outwork me. Because I know I
think big and I know I'm clear about what
I want to do in my life, but this is what
happened here's to you. Enjoy this celebration
tonight. It's absolutely your show." No animosity.
No issues. No nothing. Came back that night,
pages and pages of notes that night. Okay?
On what I did wrong. On what was my mistake.
On what I stopped doing. I was not reading.
I was not working. I had let my body go. I
was not exercising. I was not edgy. I was
not staying on point with certain areas to
improve. I was not marketing as good. There
were certain things I was not happy about.
I made a list of it. Boom. The rest is history.
You can't even compare the numbers now, but
the rest is history. Because we had to improve.
Now by the way, there's a lot of other people
that are going to do it better than you, faster
than you, all that other. This doesn't mean
you're going to beat everybody. You can do
this assessment and your name is Clyde Drexler
and you're probably never going to be better
than Michael Jordan. You can do this assessment
and you may be Lamar Odom and you're never
going to be better than Kobe Bryant. But hey,
why not reach your capacity? Why not get better
than what you are today? Why do you keep justifying?
Why do you keep saying all these sorts of
things? Until a small thinker doesn't identify
this and address it, I hate to say it to you,
not a lot's going to change. But it all starts
with you realizing what I said at the beginning
of the video: nobody is a bigger enemy to
you, not the enemy, not the competition, not
the client, not the industry, nobody is a
bigger enemy to you than the way you think.If
you can fix the thinking here, the world is
yours. That's the biggest challenge for small
thinking entrepreneurs. So, that's my message
to you. If you have any questions or thoughts
about it, comment on the bottom, and if you
haven't subscribed to this channel, please
make sure there's somewhere here you can click
to subscribe and if you're watching this video
on a completely different website you can
always come back to PatrickBetDavid.com and
you'll get a bunch of other content on this
website. Thanks for watching everybody. Take
care. Bye bye.